well check this out you're gonna love
this you're gonna
love this there's a new ben and jerry's
ice cream flavor
ready to change the world ben and
jerry's and colin kaepernick are teaming
up
and the struggle against police violence
systemic racism
is this real why are you talking about
oh my god this is from the ben and
jerry's
youtube post they got why why are they
i'll tell you this right now these black
people that are doing this voiceover
are playing their blackness up so much
in the voice
that's right y'all ben and jerry's what
that's like dude come on stop ready
so when i heard that i went down to make
sure it wasn't like a [ __ ] parody or
something this is real it's from their
website
ready to change the world ben and
jerry's and cop oh you see how they
spell world
yeah i know no no no hold on you don't
get it because like world is
traditionally spelled w-o-r-l-d
you know what would be a great
commercial for this is if you go
uh you'd be like yo go get me some ice
cream and you're like okay and you're
like in a 7-eleven walking around and
then you open up the crab and you go
yo royce heads up go along and then you
just drop it and then we just keep
going no hang on we got another one and
i throw it way
past you and it hits the [ __ ] slurpee
machine it just knocks cups over and i'm
like
hang on we got two more downs and pull
out another one and just oh and it just
hits the indian dude
and then i and then i get kicked out of
the 7-eleven for throwing ice cream
around and hitting everybody and as the
cops are arresting me i'm like
this is racism i got it but how about
this for more realistic commercial
you have colin kaepernick throwing the
ice cream to somebody and he keeps
missing
then alex smith comes in and pushes him
out of the way and he throws a perfect
spiral to him
and kaepernick has to leave uh
you know what it's it's actually you
just throwing the [ __ ] ice cream
around
and alex alex smith walking around with
a clipboard going
concussion protocols are [ __ ] i was
fine
i was fine dude they [ __ ] jesus
christ man
i was fine i told them i was fine
so is this frozen yogurt no it's
non-dairy so imagine getting a ben and
jerry's named after you
and you have the non-dairy hilarious
that is the worst one that is disgusting
and by the way that means that this one
is going to be one of the worst selling
ben and jerry's and it's going to
continue colin kaepernick's um
legacy of failure oh yeah no one's gonna
who's gonna buy this are you
have you ever been at a grocery store
and been like i'm gonna get the
non-dairy ben
jerry's but that's why because i was
looking and i was going i was like wait
a minute fudge chips graham cracker
chocolate cookie i'm i'm thinking i
look i've always had a thing with ben
and jerry's i despise their politics
i hate the people they use as
spokespeople i do not want to give money
to that company
but i do because their ice cream is
[ __ ] ridiculously good it really is
i hate stephen colbert but i love
america dream is
delicious it's amazing and there's they
have other flavors that are just
i love ben jerry's ice cream i will say
it's not my favorite i like haagen-dazs
more
but i when i see ben jerry's in the
freezer and it's one of the flavors i
like i'm like
hell yeah i'm gonna grab some ben and
jerry's so i would have had this i would
have actually tried this and been like
look i hate kaepernick but the the list
of ingredients sounds really good
but it's the non-dairy it's terrible so
you're going to make it in water
and the sales are going to be down and
they're going to get and watch there's
going to be a [ __ ] blog
article in a couple months where they're
like colin kaepernick
colin kaepernick ben and jerry's ice
cream is the least selling brand
is it because america's racist like no
it's because it's non-dairy should we
explore our racist attitudes towards ice
cream and you're like well no
just put milk in it if you just put milk
and cream in it i'll eat it
uh dr till says uh it says yeah he goes
i i'm horrifically lactose intolerant
oh i see so you support kaepernick i'm
just gonna gaslight people from now on
i'm gaslighting people poor guys those
from dollar anything
do you mean to say yeah the same way
people like he'll do to oscar's be like
you know what man trump really let me
down on some of his policies oh so you
want to keep trump
waiting what why don't you say that
oh you're pro biden now and you're like
i know not at any point did i say that
[ __ ] teaming up and the struggle
against police violence
these poor cops who did nothing by the
way somebody in the chat said uh oh
blt said i won't spend that kind of
money on ice cream so what are you one
of those gross people that eats poor
people ice cream
you want to don't buy ice cream yeah if
you're going to buy one of those it's
mostly water
you know the one that gets the frozen
the ice layer on top of the
low quality yeah no gary look get real
ice cream don't [ __ ] get ice cream
i'm sorry but i'm gonna put [ __ ] up on
my foot down here
i know we're talking about police
violence but this seems to be more
important
yeah do you understand cheap ice cream
you got to get a nice like a
heavy ice cream it needs to be heavy and
if you're gonna get a big jug like
sometimes you get a big jug get like a
blue bell
blue bell's good like that's a good real
ice cream it needs to be more cream
if i told you hey do me a favor we're
gonna have some ice cream
get some ice cream and you came back
with poor people ice cream
i would punch you right in the [ __ ]
stomach i look
i'm not saying like there aren't some
things in life that you should save
money on
there's plenty of food items that i'll
go get the cheap stuff because that's
it's fine like it'll pass like there's
certain things ice cream's not one of
them
ice cream's not one of them if you're
gonna either get good ice cream
or it's like soda same thing with soda
yeah do not bring rc cola in here or a
store brand [ __ ] kill you yes
honestly even pepsi i'd be a mild
because it's still a but it's still
but i can't but i wouldn't say anything
i'd be like oh okay you got pepsi
but like anything below pepsi i would
[ __ ] lay into somebody and go why did
you bring this like if you like if
you know we i've said it before but
pepsi slogan should be his pepsi okay
because that's what you know if you're
at a restaurant it's like oh we don't
have pepsi okay and you normally go okay
but i've never been to a restaurant and
i said is rc cola
okay i'll say like no i'll have water
and i'll even say this
uh cereal you can get the cheap stuff
doesn't bother me as much i would prefer
the brand name cereal
but i would be less angry if somebody
brought the big bag of cereal
than if they brought me cheap like store
brand
ice cream i would be like the cereal i'd
be like
dad just pour some milk over and eat it
it's still cereal but you bring some
[ __ ] off-brand ice cream i will be
fury like roy said with the [ __ ] coat
of ice on the top you like
the freezer burn you're like this is
terrible
enough in the struggle against police
that's right
racism and why what does that have to do
with ice cream wait
wait wait wait wait ice cream it's like
the meme ice cream
what is what is ending okay first off
know your base here okay
the people that are buying ben and
jerry's are white people
i mean your company's in vermont hey yo
baby girl when you go up to the store
today
hey baby when you go pay the power bill
i'll pronounce scott do me a favor stop
and get me some ben and jerry's please
maybe you know i love benny j
something that's never been said baby
can you go get me some ben jerry's or
some vegan cheese baby girl please
baby i know you just got your tax check
can you do me a favor you got your
stimulus
you go get me some ben and jerry's
please
[Laughter]
it's time to dismantle systems of
oppression
with non-dairy ice cream also i love the
fact that they go we gotta dismantle
systems of oppression
but then they just show footage of jails
which look
i i am all for prison reform i'm all for
talking police reform
but we can't just shut the jails down i
don't think that's a good
i don't i really don't think that's a
good plan
jb says didn't harris put them all in
jail yeah
he she did to saw the tweet that
somebody posted today and i thought it
was fantastic
it says starting today will be the first
time ever we have a vice president
who accused the president of yeah i saw
that i retweeted that one last night i
was
howling laughing at that one yeah
and create alternatives rooted in
community accountability
and well-being why are they playing this
luke cage music too
this this this is so annoying it's
pandering but it's so ham-fisted like
it's a blaxploitation film
i would be if i were black i would be
offended by this
i i don't understand how
i don't know why some of you guys fall
so easily for these tricks
but my god if i saw this commercial i'd
be going like
is this what you think black people are
is this
did you just try to summarize black
people with a [ __ ]
isaac hayes riff and a couple of [ __ ]
pandering shots of colin kaepernick
and go yeah y'all we need to shut down
the jails
like that's it's just like hey man you
ever notice how white folk be driving
and walking differently and [ __ ] and
you're like okay this is
he says i'm gonna go this is what
resistance looks like
[Music]
is this one here a special
he seems like you know what i it's funny
because i know everybody hates
kaepernick hannibal burst is there
this whack i i is as much as
actually looks like cameron um two days
in a row with a camera on reference
but other shows because it really does
look like him look like cameron or kind
of looks like mace
oh mason beth but
the thing is like everybody hates
kaepernick right kaepernick's the one in
this whole situation that i'm the least
mad at
because he's literally just a guy that
knew his football career was over
yeah and they gave him they're like dude
you want to stay relevant and paid
forever and he's like
sure it's the media i hate it's the
people that create this [ __ ]
the guys in the in the [ __ ] in the
pitch rooms that are like
maybe we'll get colin kaepernick and uh
you know use him as some sort of symbol
i don't even hate a kaepernick because
it's like well my football career is
over
like you want 50 million dollars from
reebok anyway and he's like
hell yeah it's i don't even blame him
and it's rooted in joy love and justice
all of colin's proceeds from our new
certified vegan non-dairy flavor go to
no
this is this is the perfect example of
not knowing your audience at all
because you know they had a meeting and
they went we're going to get the we got
to get the black
we got to get the blacks eating ben and
jerry's i got an idea
we'll do a kaepernick thing we'll do a
whole blm angle
i do a whole a cab thing right we did
this thing and we sell it and then
somebody was like
what if we made it non-dairy and vegan
and everybody's like done
and now they're like wait a minute that
was a terror who's whose idea was it to
do with the non-dairy vegan
they would go to know your rights camp
an organization
know your rights camp what's know your
rights camp
go to know your rights camp an
organization he launched in 2016
to advance the liberation of black and
brown people
from where from what are they being
liberated from from where
is jim crow still going on actually you
know what wait a minute i might be on
board
here where what are we liberating where
are we liberating from
and more importantly colin where are we
sending them to
because i might be on board for this if
you hey listen
i'm with you this is america is not for
everyone
i get it some people might find this
place to be
oppressive and brutish and terrible
and you know i'm just saying that where
did you
have in mind did you want to send them
to because i might
i might chip a couple of bucks into the
gofundme if we're
if we're raising up money to ship
people out to somewhere they'd be more
happy
let's serve up some joy on the journey
to justice together
we can change the world
like honestly raise your hand if
look at the ratio
if you if you honestly if
if black people and not even black
people but just this
this segment of black people the the
colin kaepernick i'm so oppressed even
though i'm my own worst enemy group of
black people
um if they all started a change.org
petition or like a gofundme and they
said look we'll leave
we're gonna go take over some other
place in the world and we're gonna build
our own wakanda
would you guys donate to that gofundme
because i feel like i would i feel like
i'd go
yeah fine if you're gonna go go here
he's [ __ ] he's a hundred bucks
because it beats sitting around
complaining right like i look at this
the way i look at people
in any station in life when they just
sit around and complain all the time and
you're like then change it
yeah didn't change it i hate this
[ __ ] job [ __ ] job suck
[ __ ] hate this job like i got friends
with lego post every day about how they
hate their job and i'm like
then get a new job oh right i'm just
gonna go get another job and you're like
yeah
if you're this miserable that you feel
the need every day to complain about the
same thing
change the thing you're complaining
about every day i feel like that's a
fair thing
ben jerry's was founded by uh ben
cohen and jerry greenfield oh yeah well
we always knew that that was
yeah uh although griffin college it's
business partners opening ice cream
uh an ice cream parlor together
hmm so are you gonna try it
i really want to just see if i could get
permission to go film
in a store just so i could do the colin
kaepernick just throwing
just throwing his ice cream and missing
every [ __ ] target
yo heads up just hitting people right in
the legs of the ball
what the [ __ ] man sorry